le visage de cette fillette a bouleversé
la france entière 11 août 1987 à hauteur
de suèvres des employés de l'autoroute
découvre le corps sans vie d'une
fillette elle est vraisemblablement un
jet de 3 à 5 ans et porte une robe à
carreaux morsure traces de fer à
repasser coup et contusions l'autopsié
révélera plus tard de multiples mauvais
traitement intérieur à son décès à
l'époque il n'est pas encore question de
relevés d'empreintes génétiques seules
son groupe sanguin et identifié peu
après sa mort l'enfant est enterré sur
la commune de ce faible kléber cousin en
était le maire à l'époque pour nous
chanter des airs on s'affaire une
pénible très pénible
mais nous l'avons vécu et puis nous
vivait encore voyez tous toutes ces
fleurs qui sont encore il ya beaucoup
d'artificiel mais est encore des naturel
vous avez des gens de passage
ayant appris cette triste affaire par la
presse les temps de passage s'arrête et
cherche cimetière de chèvre et pourvoir
à cette petite tombe
pour nous c'est la petite de ladish
et ce sera toujours la petite de ladish
en 1993 jacques pradel et son émission
témoin numéro 1 relance la sphère les
gendarmes reçoivent de nombreux appels
et tentent quelques pistes l'une d'entre
elles les conduira en tunisie et puis
plus rien les juges se succèdent et en
1997 un non lieu est prononcé en 2007
quelques mois avant la prescription
définitive le procureur de la république
de blois ouvre une nouvelle information
judiciaire pour mauvais traitement sur
mineur homicide et recel de cadavre et
justement de penser ce journal cet appel
à témoins lancé par la justice regarder
un numéro de téléphone le 06 46 17 05 59
le signalement l'appel à témoins enfants
95 cm vous le voyez 20 kg cheveux bruns
bouclés les yeux noirs 3 à 5 ans elle
portait une robe blanche à carreaux de
type méditerranéen voilà